[Música]
en primera plana
carlos bienvenidos en primera plana un
programa de radio francia internacional
france24 esta semana ponemos el foco
aquí en francia ya saben que el
presidente macrón ha decretado toques de
queda en nueve ciudades francesas para
ello me acompañan en este estudio tres
invitados ya les presento a joan
cortinas muñoz sociólogo del instituto
de ciencias políticas de parís y experto
en pool en políticas de salud bienvenido
joan gracias carlos me conviene también
mi compañera florencia ángeles
corresponsal de la doble be de colombia
aquí en francia bienvenido flar y más de
humanidad y me convenga también miguel
martínez corresponsable tvazteca
bienvenido miguel no seas carlos francia
instaura el 'toque de queda' hoy en
primera plana
[Música]
bueno pues ya lo saben francia vuelve a
restringir las libertades para evitar
una nueva catástrofe sanitaria el
presidente manuel macrón ha decretado un
toque de queda en parís en su región en
ocho grandes ciudades francesas donde el
número de casos de kobe se ha disparado
hasta niveles preocupantes el toque de
queda vigente a partir del sábado entre
las nueve de la noche y las seis de la
mañana se prolongará durante un mínimo
de cuatro semanas así lo anunciaba el
presidente macro en una intervención por
televisión el pasado miércoles por la
noche pero cree decisión que nos dé
algún gil cdc acude a google quizás a
pique a la gestión de fonz jurídicas y
el anuncio del presidente macrón esas
nueve ciudades donde va a aplicarse el
toque de queda una medida extraordinaria
para corregir los datos de una segunda
ola disparada se pueden imaginar que
esta situación ha generado un gran eco
en la prensa francesa vamos a reportar
pasar algunas portadas que nos deja la
prensa diario libération con una de sus
icónicas portadas bajo el título buenas
noches
le figaro escoge esta frase del discurso
de macrón toque de queda para retomar el
control el católico lakua por su parte
titula en su portada
kobe la hora del toque de queda bueno yo
quizás la primera pregunta este toque de
queda es una medida proporcional a la
situación que se está viviendo a la
misma que en francia es difícil
responder si es proporcionado o no
porque disponemos de muy pocos datos
desde la población tenemos los datos de
contaminación tenemos los datos de
muertos pero tenemos muchos menos datos
sobre cómo han habido han ido las otras
medidas es decir que ha pasado porque
han funcionado porque no han funcionado
proporciona seguramente es muy difícil
juzgarlo a mí si lo han hecho
seguramente es porque tienen sus razones
para hacerlo para mí el problema se
sitúa en otra cuestión que seguramente
discutiremos después que es la
estrategia de comunicación que se
utiliza para informar a la población
para dar razón de esta medida como tú
dices extraordinaria y realmente
consagrado dedicada a momentos muy
excepcionales lo hablaremos de esa
estrategia de comunicación pero cuanto
menos lo que vemos ya al presidente
salir de nuevo a la primera
la primera línea hasta ahora veíamos al
primer ministro francés y en este caso
quizá por la gravedad de la situación
luego lo comentamos pero antes me
gustaría florencia miguel medida
proporcionada este toque de queda
yo pienso que sí sobre todo cuando vemos
al menos lo que se ha dicho las últimas
semanas es que la tasa de incidencia en
los jóvenes está aumentando de manera
pues importante y justamente es una de
las medidas dirigidas a este sector de
la población que a veces quizá está un
poco más vaya un poco más ligero digamos
en las medidas restrictivas pero también
yo creo que se debe de acompañar de
otras medidas no únicamente apostarle a
la toque de queda sino también mejorar
en esta cuestión de los tests pienso que
también por ahí es una de las fallas que
se tiene que corregir entre otras por
parte de la estrategia del gobierno
también no acompañando lo que hice
flores también encontrar este problema
que está viviendo hoy en día a parís
sobre todo con el transporte público la
saturación del transporte público que no
se va a ver impactado por este toque de
queda sino que el transporte va a seguir
todo el día y en la noche bueno va la
vida nocturna vamos a decir de trabajo
nocturno eso va a continuar y eso y creo
que que hiciera énfasis en eso porque el
toque de queda
estará para la población en general pero
todo lo demás va a seguir funcionando
los aeropuertos van a seguir abiertos
hablo específicamente del lugar donde se
registró que es donde sea
todos los restaurantes vienen a recibir
toda la comida eso funciona a las 4 3 4
la mañana entonces eso no se va a parar
entonces hay que hay que ver realmente
vamos a ver dentro de cuatro semanas
como cómo está evolucionando la
situación del tour que yo sé todo porque
el toque de queda para explicar a
nuestros oyentes y nuestros espectadores
viene a ser una especie confinamiento
nocturno empieza a partir de las nueve
de la noche hasta las seis de la mañana
vendría a ser un confinamiento nocturno
es una medida johann que pone en el
punto de mira a la esfera privada a las
reuniones familiares a los reuniones de
amigos escuchamos el discurso de macro
en el otro día y esa esfera privada era
casi el el eje troncal de su discurso
absolutamente es decir como decía
florencia evidente se ha identificado
que uno de los vectores de contaminación
son los 18 30 años más o menos
evidentemente en qué situaciones en
situaciones pues más de salida etcétera
pero hay hay que mencionar que si uno
mira la lista y como habéis visto estos
últimos días en lugar de contaminación
privilegiada de en francia actualmente
no son los bares ni los restaurantes son
los lugares de trabajo privados y
públicos las escuelas los liceos y las
universidades evidentemente no es muy
difícil jugar con eso y cerrarla
siempres estamos de acuerdo pero aquí
y contextualizar en los bares o
restaurante los jóvenes no son el primer
vector de contaminación son otros
lugares obviamente esta media está
claramente dirigida a la vida nocturno
obviamente y por lo tanto la gente que
sale por lo tanto los más jóvenes que
hacen este tipo de fiestas mi pregunta
sigue siendo la misma es decir había que
llegar hasta aquí seguramente yo no lo
sé porque no tengo los datos pero no
había medidas intermedias antes de
llegar aquí se podía haberlo hecho de
otra manera podríamos haber mejorado
otras cosas seguramente todo al mismo
tiempo tengo una elección porque no el
toque de queda pero si va acompañado
seguramente de otras medidas que nos
eviten medidas tan drásticas y
excepcionales como un toque de queda sin
embargo la implementación del toque de
queda poner sobre la mesa múltiples
incógnitas y múltiples problemas el
primero de ellos la aceptación social
florencia van a aceptar los franceses
este toque de queda es muy curioso
porque a mí me llamó la atención de las
primeras reacciones era ya no sólo a lo
que implica el toque de queda o este
confinamiento en el corno era justamente
a esa manera de decirlo muchos decían
porque recorrimos un lenguaje de guerra
porque es la de toque de queda y no
confinamiento nocturno precisamente no
pues ya de ahí vemos este rechazo
justamente
de queda porque no es lo mismo cuando
parís vivía las horas negras la
acotación así por ejemplo que ahí si se
han instaurado en un poco de abogado del
en el otro lado hay quienes dicen
que si a la población no se le habla con
un lenguaje un poco más duro hay
relajación también y yo creo que por eso
también se eligió esta palabra no pero
yo creo que sí yo creo que sí es una
manera justamente de elevarlo a una
situación de gravedad a una situación de
urgencia porque además hay que
puntualizar también que además del toque
de queda se declaró otra vez estado de
emergencia sanitaria a partir del
miércoles pasado entonces están con ese
lenguaje espero que finalmente los
franceses comprendan bueno nosotros pues
esto los que vivimos aquí en francia no
comprendamos la importancia de cumplir
las medidas y de la gravedad porque otra
vez estamos a cifras que veíamos al
inicio de la epidemia casi casi miguel
bazze edad o socialmente vamos a ver
porque a esto también va a acompañado la
comunicación del gobierno que vamos a
hablar en un momento y la gente le ha
costado mucho en entender por qué vivo
una cacofonía vio vamos a decir un poco
de improvisación por parte del gobierno
francés
llegar hasta estas medidas como vistes y
si realmente era necesario bueno yo creo
que desde que inició esta crisis
hablamos de una segunda ola que va a
venir justamente en este periodo
otoño invierno 2020 y bueno y el
gobierno tuvo que esperar siete meses y
llegar a una medida drástica sin haber
tomado antes unas medidas en el verano a
ver seguir con ciertos confinamiento
ciertos medidas restrictivas para la
población yo creo que la población hoy
en día está un poco por ejemplo para
incidir en esas cacofonías una de ellas
la de las más comentadas que en francia
ha sido la doctrina de la mascarilla
empezamos el verano con una mascarilla
voluntaria y luego terminamos con la
mascarilla obligatoria quizá ese tipo de
vaivenes en el gobierno es lo que no he
entendido la población lo vemos también
ahorita que van a empezar las vacaciones
y entonces una parte del gobierno dice
sigue a los a la gente no reserven
váyanse de bueno aunque reservamos
entonces vamos el virus de una región a
otra de la alerta máxima a las regiones
que están tan tocadas yo creo que sí hay
bastantes errores del gobierno y es ahí
también que por eso los pues la
población está no confiando en todas las
medidas y a veces diciendo bueno de que
sí
que me pongan la máscara en mesas de 2
meses no me la pone ahora sí por qué no
la aceptación de la población pasa por
la adhesión a las medidas que están
tomadas y eso pasa por dos vectores
esencialmente generan alguna la
comprensión es decir que la gente
comprenda y entienda como racional la
decisión que se ha tomado y para eso
hace falta mucha explicación que
encuentro que aún no está ahí y el
segundo vector justamente es un poco a
la coherencia es decir si tú como decía
antes no dices eso no empezó con la
máscara de voluntad y empezó con la
mascarilla no sirve
que es mucho más grave si siguió con las
elecciones municipales ir a votar no hay
ningún riesgo siguió con la dimisión de
la ministra de salud la dimisión entre
comillas que luego escribió un por un
artículo en el demonio diciendo que de
una era una máscara de ser una comedia
lo que estaba lo quería ósea habido
muchos problemas de incoherencia dentro
de la comunicación políticas y eso
genera un problema muy serio yo creo que
va a durar bastante tiempo de adhesión a
todos los mensajes de común del del
presidente y de su gobierno no es verdad
que es una situación a veces de
cacofonía estamos nombrando
el gobierno francés porque es el tema
que nos convoca pero que se está viendo
casi en todos los países decir en españa
con un gobierno del signo político
distinto pues también hay mensajes
incoherentes lo estamos viendo en
katsina varios puntos américa latina'
finalmente está estábamos viendo esto y
finalmente yo creo que lo triste es que
no se aprenda de los errores llevamos ya
con este virus varios meses yo creo que
el gobierno ahora puede ser claro y
decir ok que cometimos estos errores de
comunicación las cosas están así pero
mientras no explican las cosas claras la
gente la verdad es que no va a tomar en
serio las medidas y luego está el
problema de logística claro se impone un
toque de queda y a partir de ahora se
vuelve que digamos al sistema del
confinamiento a través de at estaciones
que permitirán salir a la calle durante
ese periodo en el que no se puede por
motivos de causa mayor problemas de
salud o bien por motivo laboral y si no
multas claro no puede el gobierno no
puede tener un policía en cada calle
para comprobar el toque de queda
va a ser lo suficientemente disuasorio
las multas para respetar el toque de
queda
ayer hablaba el ministro de interior que
ponen 12 mil policías extras para
dedicados exclusivamente a seguir el
respeto del toque de queda evidentemente
estamos en lo mismo sería mucho más sano
si la gente adhiriera a la medida es
decir que se hubiera habido todo un
trabajo de explicación de pedagogía que
la gente dijera no tuvieran necesidad de
salir a la calle va a ser necesario creo
que la gente va a respetar el toque de
queda con lo cual me parece que es
12.000 policías más los habituales es
posible que sea suficiente no es el
primer toque de queda que se hace en
francia durante estos meses que es algo
que la población a veces no sabe pero en
el departamento de la guyana durante
este verano si un 'toque de queda' de
similares características y se consiguió
reducir las cifras de contaminación es
no sé el otro dia macrón hablaba de ese
ejemplo no para emular un poco lo que ha
pasado en guyana
yo creo que bueno yo creo que en guyana
fue mucho más estricto de lo que estamos
dirigiendo en parís o lo que vamos a
vivir a partir de este fin de semana y
después regresando también con el tema
de la comunicación yo creo que la gente
en un inicio va a tener porque el
gobierno así es
no nos dice que durante los primeros
días va a haber pedagogía para el toque
de queda entonces empezamos o no
empezamos la primera el primer fin de
semana que va a ser este seguramente va
a haber mucha gente que va a salir estoy
seguro y bueno les va no los van a
multar todavía y será hasta dentro una
semana o semana y media que van a ver
realmente meter la medida de montar a la
gente sí y ahora además hay en caso de
reincidencia una multa que es más
importante e incluso seis meses de
prisión a lo mejor y eso les da un poco
en este momento y vamos a intentar
comparar un poco francia con la
situación de los otros países europeos
del entorno de francia será en unos
instantes aquí en primera plana esta
hora
[Música]
el turismo en eeuu está prácticamente
paralizado las restricciones de viajes
impuestas por el gobierno de donald
trump cuando empezó la pandemia y que
aún están vigentes han hecho que algunas
industrias estén en serios problemas las
aerolíneas que se vieron obligadas a
cancelar la mayoría de sus rutas poco a
poco intentan volver a la normalidad a
medida que se reabre la economía pero no
hay viajes de negocios ni vacaciones y
hay miedo a volar por la posibilidad de
contagio así que en el país
norteamericano ya se ha anunciado más de
40 mil despidos en american airlines
delta y united la administración de eeuu
ha impulsado un paquete de estímulo
económico para estas empresas en total
se van a destinar más de 25 mil millones
de dólares con un objetivo principal
evitar los despidos masivos sin embargo
expertos financieros advierten que el
sector turístico está viviendo una
crisis sin precedentes y es muy probable
que incluso algunas aerolíneas se vean
obligadas a desaparecer ante la
incapacidad de llevar una operación
empresarial que no está funcionando a
pleno rendimiento
[Música]
pocas semanas después de haberse
conocido que el combi 19 había llegado a
irán a comienzos de febrero el gobierno
anunció una ayuda de 87 millones de
dólares en préstamos para las aerolíneas
que están divididas en dos grandes
bloques una son muy pequeñas que cubren
las rutas nacionales que aunque han
estado abiertas se han reducido en su
transporte un 50% en los últimos meses y
las otras dos son las dos grandes
aerolíneas una pública que es granero y
la otra privada mahan héroes que son las
que cubren las rutas internacionales
desde irán y que han sido las más
afectadas pues si bien algunas de esas
rutas se han abierto el tránsito es muy
poco y se dice que se ha reducido un 91
por ciento en el transporte de pasajeros
lo que hace aún más crítica la situación
de estas aerolíneas que vienen desde
hace años siendo afectadas por las
sanciones económicas con las que está
sometida irán
[Música]
las reiteradas peticiones de políticos
no solamente aquí en alemania sino
también en otras partes de europa para
que la gente no viaje en estas épocas y
así pueda reducir las posibilidades de
contagio no ha hecho sino aumentar esa
sensación de crisis en el sector de las
aerolíneas aquí en alemania en
particular en lufthansa que es la
principal del país hace unos meses
lufthansa llegó a un acuerdo con el
gobierno nacional para un
multimillonario paquete de rescate
evaluado en unos nueve mil millones de
euros pero esto no ha impedido que en
las últimas semanas continúen los
titulares negativos sobre luz anza que
tuvo que anunciar nuevas medidas de
ahorro
lufthansa anunció la reducción de su
flota la cancelación de puestos de
trabajo y eso es encontrar que unos 650
mil viajeros continúan esperando que se
les devuelva su dinero por viajes
cancelados un tema todo esto muy
preocupante no solamente a nivel
económico sino también a nivel político
pues el acuerdo alcanzado hace unos
meses llevó a que el gobierno nacional
se convierta
en uno de los principales accionistas de
lufthansa
[Música]
continuamos aquí en primera plana esta
semana analizando estas medidas de
excepción instauradas en francia el otro
día por el presidente manuel macro ya
saben el toque de queda a partir de
ahora y nueve ciudades francesas lo
hacemos con mis compañeros
florencia ángeles corresponsal de la
doble de colombia miguel martínez
corresponsal de tv azteca y el sociólogo
y experto en políticas de salud joan
cortinas muñoz macrón con su aparición
del pasado miércoles de un paso a la
primera línea de batalla en esta segunda
ola hasta ahora era su primer ministro
que se había encargado un poco de lidiar
con toda la situación porque macrón
decide ahora ocupar este espacio y dar
la cara
quizá la gravedad no permitía que no lo
hiciese que la gravedad pero también el
hecho de que no se veía un avance
significativo en las medidas tomadas
anteriormente en los días recientes por
los gobiernos locales de hecho se
advirtió por parte del primer ministro
jan castex que se daba la mano a las
autoridades locales ojo después de
quemarse ya le reclamó de que hubieran
cerrado bares y restaurantes dijo que le
damos 15 días para que estas medidas se
ve que no
hay gran avance y yo creo que es la
también la manera quizá de terminar con
las cacofonías que hablábamos hace unos
instantes
vamos a escuchar un extracto del
discurso del pasado miércoles por la
noche en televisión del presidente
matrona mundo ha generado la difusión de
los dados por botella lisos
debemos frenar la propagación del virus
para empezar para proteger a los demás
sobre todo a los más vulnerables pero
también a nuestro sistema de salud
de miguel
aparición de macrón primera línea de
batalla la grave de las cifras vacían
inevitable pues si lo hace inevitable
pero también hay una otra cuestión de
aquí que vemos muy claro en su discurso
entre comillas porque no es un mensaje a
la nación nuclear se de manera oficial
es una entrevista es una entrevista con
dos criaturas 30 milenios en 35 minutos
entonces si lo obliga a dar un poco más
de explicaciones de realmente lo que lo
que va a tomar lo las medidas que van a
implementar y explicar a la población
que quedó también un poco al aire porque
al siguiente día tuvo que es el primer
ministro y sus ministros quienes dan más
concretamente que en qué va a consistir
cada una ayuda específicamente durante
los últimos días los expertos que
asesoran a macrón en su consejo
científico a la hora de tomar decisiones
tampoco se habían puesto de acuerdo
sobre la conveniencia o no de establecer
medidas más duras como el toque de queda
hay quienes piensan que endurecer la
situación resultará menos dañino
económica socialmente que el simple
cierre de algunos establecimientos otros
opinan que tendrá consecuencias muy
negativas para sectores de actividad que
ya han sufrido mucho
donde se posicionan ustedes es muy
complicado claro este es el eterno
debate entre el equilibrio entre salud y
economía que es casi imposible
hay varios equilibrios de crisis salud
economía salud y política salud y
elecciones hay muchos tuvo la pregunta
que hacía antes no olvidemos que eduard
philip el ministro que macro
digamos liberó después de la epidemia de
la primera ola perdón había acogido una
popularidad increíble durante el momento
de la pandemia porque macrón vuelve pues
seguramente no da una razón de este tipo
está vinculado en teoría todo esto para
decir que hay muchos intereses
evidentemente vinculados consejo
científico hay médicos que también hay
sociólogos economistas y antropólogos
hay distintas visiones no es muy difícil
de responder a este tipo de preguntas
pero luego lo que lo que es importante y
lo que me parece más más crucial no es
decir no hay que olvidar que si toma
esta medida es porque no hay suficientes
camas de cuidados intensivos que eso no
hay que olvidarlo y que toda medida de
este tipo hay que darle la mano derecha
la sanción y la mano izquierda es decir
qué pasa con la gente que va a estar muy
afectada por este tipo de mirarlas
no va a ser suficiente vamos a ampliar
el zoom sobre otros países porque vemos
a países como españa o como francia que
están teniendo muchos problemas para
controlar esta segunda ola y al revés
italia por ejemplo con tantos problemas
durante la primera ahora está
controlando más o menos bien la
situación a qué se debe esta situación
tanto paradójica yo creo que bueno hay
varios factores en cuanto al gobierno y
las medidas e italia vivió una
reapertura muy progresiva contra lo que
vivimos en francia yo creo que también
desde ahí parten los errores del
gobierno que pasamos el confinamiento
una apertura muy rápida y también yo
creo que la gente con este mensaje se
puede abrir todo dijo a la epidemia ya
pasó ya estamos bien en el verano todo
el mundo viajo todo el mundo estuvo en
reunión ahí fue que empezó realmente
otra vez
los contagios a subir y a italia lo ha
hecho de una manera más lenta incluso
italia no ha reabierto los estadios cosa
que aquí ya se hizo también que hubo una
restricción de vuelos más importantes y
en italia se regreso algunas
restricciones una vez que hubo la
reapertura vieron que no sabe
funcionando y que mandaban los contagios
dieron marcha atrás no les dijo
de tomar estas decisiones de nuevo y
también en la escuela por ejemplo la
escuela reabrió 15 días después que lo
que vimos aquí en francia te digo fue
poco a poco lento y viano también
recordemos que italia fue el país más
afectado de la primera ola y veíamos
estos carros militares con los cadáveres
que llevaban entonces creo que eso
también impactó muchísimo a los
italianos allá también hablaba yo
los italianos justamente en parís
condiciones que en italia la familia es
muy importante quizá también hay unos
lazos más más fuertes no lo sé no digo
que en francia no existan pero en otro
tipo de relaciones sociológica
son varios factores pero del lado del
gobierno lo que para mí es la reapertura
progresía francia no es el único país
desde luego europeo con fuertes
restricciones orán ha decretado un
confinamiento parcial esta misma semana
bueno el reino unido- prohibidas las
visitas ya directamente en casa a
bélgica también bueno se multiplican las
las restricciones casi por todo el mapa
europeo semana a semana lo apunta antes
florencia se hicieron mal las cosas
durante los desconocimientos
seguramente es decir florencia creo que
estoy de acuerdo con ella ha habido
pasamos de un confinamiento muy y muy
estricto a bueno ya todo se abre todo el
mundo puede viajar con esa contradicción
o instancia cognitiva de nuevo viaje no
hay ningún problema vayan de vacaciones
aunque sea en francia no pero entonces
se hizo para mí tal vez demasiado rápido
pero eso aún no no yo creo que es muy
difícil acusar a cualquier gobierno como
tú dices sea el signo que sea porque es
un aprendizaje pero ahí está para mí a
lo que tendría que ser también un tono
de comunicación es decir estamos
aprendiendo bueno pues decir lo que
estáis aprendiendo que a ver que hemos
aprendido porque seguramente han
aprendido cosas nos hemos equivocado no
hay ningún problema es normal esa
pandemia no la hemos vivido pero es
humildad no sé cómo explicarlo es esa
pedagogía esa humildad
y aquí parece que les da miedo
justamente ponerse en esa debilidad
entre comillas que no lo es y es más
claro decir esto justamente estamos
aprendiendo todos también de la
ciudadanía explicar las cosas y decir
vamos a así parece que paso a pasito y
vamos más seguro que de repente a abrir
confinamiento nocturno que ya no es un
informe esta semana de evaluación está
muy bien pues muy bien presenta el
informe que este señor el epidemiólogo
presenta el informe que haya pues eso es
lo que hay que hacer y decir bueno
estamos aprendiendo no no somos no hemos
nunca hemos gestionado este tipo de
riesgos estamos aprendiendo lo que hemos
aprendido hasta ahora aquí lo que no
sabemos es eso y eso nos obliga a tomar
medidas y poner un poco en ese tono que
el gobierno no tanto con el período de
confinamiento sino también creo que no
aprendieron de una cuestión que pudo
haber sido crucial para el gobierno
francés sobre el sistema hospitalario
voy a siete meses de todo lo que sucedió
en la primera fase de esta crisis hoy el
sistema hospitalario sigue saturado no
hay contratos
están saturados otra vez por kobe y
bueno no nos han hecho ningún anuncio de
mayores presupuestos mayores contratos
qué va a pasar con los sistemas de
urgencias que también no hay que
recordarlo y decirlo con todas sus
letras no nada más escogido hoy en día
el sistema hospitalario parisino está
casi al 50% de saturación únicamente por
coronavirus y de otras y el resto son
enfermedades crónicas que no se han
curado o que no se curaron por ejemplo
durante el confinamiento entonces si la
gran dijo en su intervención televisiva
que debemos acostumbrarnos a vivir con
más o menos restricciones por lo menos
hasta el verano boreal el verano aquí
francés del hemisferio norte de 2021
casi un año casi un año más como poco
creen que socialmente y me dirijo al
sociólogo ahora que concepción
socialmente hemos empezado a integrar
que el virus ha venido para quedarse y
que quizá nos hemos estado auto
engañando quizá en los primeros meses
pensando que el horizonte cercano
era es un horizonte cercano que en
realidad era imaginativo seguramente y
es sano que nos autoengañamos porque lo
que estamos viendo es muy duro entonces
es casi humano de supervivencia
y bueno estamos una sociedad muy
tecnológica muy científica donde podemos
hacer cosas increíbles por la gente
forzosamente creen que una vacuna no
debería tardar evidentemente los
expertos dicen que como pronto en el
verano de 2021 no pero socialmente
me parece importante insistir en el
hecho de que en la sociedad no es
homogénea de que hay gente que está
sufriendo mucha más que otro estamos
pensando en el cub afe en el toque de
queda actual los de libia los rovers
toda esta gente que está al margen del
mercado de trabajo pero que está ahí
esta gente va a sufrir mucho mal
entonces en ese sentido yo que me parece
importante insistir que el gobierno
también tendría que tener en cuenta
todas esas diferencias de las medidas
que se toman que no impactan a todo el
mundo por igual ya hemos criticado a los
políticos pero hagamos un poco de
crítica asociar el temor de las
autoridades y el motivo principal de las
restricciones que ha nunciado macrón es
que este ritmo como comentaba mi
compañero miguel antes del sistema
hospitalario vuelve a acercarse al
alcohol
hay conciencia social de la importancia
de este punto todavía no somos
conscientes o no hemos emitido las
imágenes a lo mejor los medios que
deberíamos haber emitido de una forma
más fuerte y más contundente para
explicar qué es ese colapso socialmente
hay una conciencia social o todavía no
existió creo que todavía no no en la
mayoría de la población y realmente a mí
es lo que también me gustaría
puntualizar es es muy fácil criticar al
gobierno y decir debería de hacer no
debería pero también uno como ciudadano
no podemos tener un policía atrás de
nosotros que nos diga hay que crecer
esto es más tu máscara no tú cubrebocas
a él no te lavas a las manos y tenemos
que tomar esta conciencia realmente de
la responsabilidad y ser menos egoísta
porque quizá hay gente que dice bueno a
mí ya me dio el coronavirus para que
traigo la máscara no y bueno pues porque
aún no se sabe todavía y puedes
contactar a otros quizás re contagiarte
o no sé también esta cuestión de había
hace unos días un debate también por lo
mismo y decían bueno dejen que los
jóvenes se contagien entre ellos y
déjenlos vivir pues si el problema es
que después llegan justamente a los
papás a los abuelitos que no tienen las
mismas condiciones y que llegan a estas
camas de reanimación y también porque
hay una
desvalorización por parte de asia hacia
el trabajo de los enfermeros de los
doctores que están al borde que no sea
justamente mejorado la situación como
decía miguel y yo porque no hay esta
conciencia yo porque bastante gol del
gobierno francés de hecho desde el
verano sí que viene apelando el primer
ministro ya que hasta esa
responsabilidad la responsabilidad pero
da la sensación que hasta que no llegan
las medidas coercitivas en realidad no
se corrigen la situación esa esa
dicotomía entre llamar o apelar a la
responsabilidad pero sabiendo que hasta
que no llega a la medida no llega la
multa no llega la la medida coercitiva
no se corrige la situación pero es
cierto también que es difícil insisto
mucho la cuestión de la comunicación lo
vimos en el mar y en otras ciudades de
por ejemplo cuando impusieron la
mascarilla voluntaria o empezaron a
poner mascarillas obligatorias en
ciertas zonas de parís entonces ibas en
una calle sin mascarilla cruzar la calle
no mascarilla entonces eso crea mucho
más claro también es cierto y hay que
decirlo con todas sus letras la cuestión
social la gente fue impresionante
después del confinamiento de todo el
mundo
a los bares en el río sena de las gentes
reunidas entonces sí creo que tener una
conciencia y posiblemente ahora que
llegan las fiestas de fin de año ahí se
puede tomar una conciencia si nos ponen
mayores medidas restricción así que no
puedes ir a ver por ejemplo a tu familia
entonces a lo mejor así podrá tomar
conciencia un poco la población francesa
pues ya ven señores en qué situación nos
encontramos aquí en francés yo diría en
casi toda europa con esta segunda ola
muchísimas gracias a los tres ha sido un
placer tenerles hoy en este en primera
plana y a todos ustedes aquí les
esperamos la próxima semana en radio
france internacional y france 24 hasta
entonces gracias
[Música]